[Music]
hi folks so ALB Omni is a properly
downloadable product which means you get
to set it up which is fine the docs are
solid and they guide you through step
byep along the way on how to do it but
I'm an engineer which means I'm always
looking for ways to optimize so today
I'm going to walk you through setting up
ALB Omni on a Google compute engine VM
with a startup script which means once
that VM comes up you'll have a full
configured ready too Omni instance to
use right off the bat I'm going to do
this in the console but one of the cool
things about the compute console is that
once you have everything configured you
can see an equivalent like g-cloud
command or a terraform config and then
you can use that in your automation if
you want so without further Ado let's
dive in here we are on our GCE page
let's go ahead and start creating an
instance okay so so I need to give it a
name uh pick your region close to you
for me it doesn't matter so I'm going to
go ahead and leave it as it is uh omn
wants at least 2 CPUs and 2 gigs of RAM
the default for VMS right now is 2 CPUs
4 gigs of RAM so I can leave that alone
too skip down to the boot dis so Omni
will want more than 10 gigs of storage
to help get things set up so I'm going
to bump that up to 20 gigs so we don't
run out of space and we'll definitely
want more space for the data so let's go
ahead and add an extra dis we need to
give the disc a name and I'm going to
bump it up to 200 gigs now you can
allocate however much space you want but
if you change it from 200 gigs remember
what you set it to because I use that
value in the startup script so just
remember whatever you've set the size to
here because you're going to need it
later um you can also choose to set the
dis to delete with the instance if you
want there's a couple things to think
about if you do if you do set it to
delete with the instance then keep in
mind that means if you delete the
instance your database data is all going
to go away conversely if you say don't
delete with the instance and you get rid
of the instance you're still going to
have a persistent disc with all your
database data sitting on it so it'll be
an extra cleanup step later if you
choose that you don't need need that
data anymore either way just think about
it when you do it so now for the magic
scroll down if you expand your
management section you're going to see
this automation box when creating a GCM
you can give it a script that'll run on
Startup and that's what we're going to
do I've created the startup script
already the link to the GitHub repo
where it lives is down in the
description below and uh there's a
couple of different ways that you can
actually use a startup script again in
the description below I've linked to the
relevant docs page where it talks about
different ways you can interact with a a
startup script for today I'm just going
to cut paste the script into the UI and
use it that way now notice when I paste
it in over here in the equivalent code
section you can see the metadata tag and
it has the full script with that tag for
startup script that's not what you'd
want if you're running on the ca CLI I
mean you can but it's much easier for
example you could pass in a local file
or if you're doing automation you could
pull in a startup script from Google
Cloud Storage those are a couple of the
other ways you can use startup scripts
and that's it I'm going to go ahead and
hit on create button and then while
that's going let's jump over here and
I'll walk you through real script what
the script is doing all right to start
off with I'm just setting a few
variables uh that dis size variable is
the one that I mentioned before where if
you've allocated a different size to
that external dis you need to change
this variable to match what the size is
I'm using it in order to find the right
dis so warning if you set it to the same
size as your boot dis not actually sure
what the script would do but it might
like format your boot dis so just make
sure that it's different than that 20
gigs for your boot dis uh the rest of
the SE this first section is formatting
mounting our external disc so that we
allocated um GCE by default doesn't
Mount any diss so that we have to do it
um I set the database directory to VAR
lib ledb Omni data which is consistent
with what postgress does so postgress
puts it in the same kind of area um the
other option might be to like install
your data directory maybe in your home
directory but if you want to do that the
startup script fires off before your
user's been created and the home
directory has been created so you can
still do it but what that means is that
the script instead of being a startup
script will be after so you'll create
the VM SSH into it then you can run the
script on the VM and it'll still all
work it'll still all run as you expect
but if you want it in your user director
you'll just have to do it as a
postcreate step instead of an all-in-one
and this next chunk it's just installing
the prerequisites for Docker and then
installing Docker itself then we grab
the ALB Omni command line tool and run
the server install and start it up
finally I install the postris client
just to make things easy uh I don't
think there's ever been a case where
I've had a postris database that I'm
interacting with that I haven't needed
the client it's small so I just went
ahead and installed it to make it
convenient and that's it so hopefully by
now let's go back to the GC instance and
try and SS into it give it a sec to log
in okay now I should be able to use psql
to log in to ALB Omni and there we go so
please know note I just did that uh
without a password because by default it
doesn't set a password on the postris
user so first thing you need to do
please go and set a password on your
postgress user then you can do whatever
you want but do that first uh and that's
it so in just a few minutes you have an
ALB ony database up and running on GCE
let us know what you think in the
comments below and if you like seeing
content like this don't forget to hit
the like button and subscribe to our
Channel thanks for
[Music]
watching